As a teenager growing up in
Greenwich Village in the late 1960s,
Steven Heller improbably
became the art director of
pioneering alternative publications
such as the New York Free Press,
Screw Magazine and
the East Village Other, before
eventually going on to work at the
New York Times and teaching at the
School of Visual Arts for decades.
He chronicles his youthful
misadventures in Growing Up
Underground, a memoir of
countercultural New York.
In November, Heller spoke at the
Reason Speakeasy, a monthly
unscripted conversation with
outspoken defenders of free thinking
and heterodoxy in an age of
cancel culture and thought police.
He regaled the Manhattan audience
with tales of arrests on obscenity
charges, how design and esthetics
can supercharge the meaning of
words and pictures,
and why so many in the
counterculture adopted exactly
the same uniform of alienation
in the name of individualism.
Well, ladies and gentlemen, I want
to thank you very much for coming
out to the most recent
Reason Speakeasy.
Today we are talking with Steven
Heller, the legendary art
director and graphic designer and
author of the phenomenal new book
Growing Up Underground:
a Memoir of Counterculture New York.
Steve started out in the late
sixties as a teenager
working at bleeding edge alternative
outlets like the New York Free Press
and Screw Magazine.
Of course, before becoming the art
director at the New York Times op ed
page for a bit and for the book
review section for many, many years,
a longtime faculty member at the
School of Visual Arts, Steve brings
an irreverent and uniquely
knowledgeable position, perspective
to discussions of how alternative
and establishment publications
influence social and cultural
change.
A fierce defender of free speech and
the First Amendment.
He didn't just witness the past half
century of boundary busting changes
to media, he
helped make it all jump off the page
and grab our attention.
Steve Heller, thanks for talking
at The Reason Speakeasy.
Thanks for inviting me.
All right. So let's start with
the memoir, which
also I will be sending all of you
a discount code
where you if you order it from the
publisher, from Princeton
Architectural Press, you can
get 20% off.
So that's real savings in
inflation.
Lots of gratitude for me.
Yes.
But it's a fantastic
personal story, but it's also a
story about a particular time and
place. Can you.
What's the kind of elevator
pitch for your memoir?
The elevator pitch is I had ten good
years
and
I kept telling stories about
them and at
a certain point, since
I've written or edited
200 books or so,
I thought it was time to
get my story on the page.
And various people
were encouraging me to do it
and
I wanted to kind of
cluster the, the years
together, how it's possible
to
get somewhere without going to
college
and still be part of the
cultural scene
and.
And I like to tell stories.
So essentially that's it.
There was no elevator pitch.
There was just calling up the editor
and saying, I have a memoir that
connects me to graphic design.
Yeah. And since they published
graphic design books, it
happened.
So the ten good years
start.
What what year did that start?
In 1966.
I was 16.
So set the stage
because you grew up in Manhattan.
I grew up in a small town in
Manhattan, Stuyvesant Town.
So what?
What was 1966, New York
like? I know there's a couple of
other people who were here
at the same time.
Tell us.
Those of us who don't remember.
Well, 1966, you could
drive a bus through
the Washington Monument.
The.
Washington Square.
The arch. Arch.
Yeah.
Which was, you know, a big
thing because if you were in
the path of a bus, they didn't stop.
Dylan was just coming on the radio
with Positively Fourth Street,
and
there was a.
A kind of anticipation of
something happening.
The Vietnam War was heating up.
There were groups that were
founded to
protest the war.
Civil rights in New York
was actually beginning to
start happening as a movement.
Hippie culture was gradually
taking over the East Village,
or what we used to call the Lower
East Side.
And music
was making a major
splash
Fillmore East, The Anderson Theater,
The Electric Circus,
the New York Academy of Music, where
I co-produced
with one of my the newspapers
I was with all these shows
at a 2,500
seat theater.